[Music]
hey you guys time once again for the
matinee show
yeah this week we actually did not go to
the theater however we saw some ones on
Netflix and on shutter so we're gonna
review those instead wasn't feeling all
that great this week man I got that
maybe got that Corona I don't know if I
die you'll know I got that Oh for [ __ ]
sake all right I mean there's like other
flus going around you there's always
specially this let me go to the theater
and then we catch Corona like you just
never wants to go never gonna go outside
again there's I I feel like some strains
are probably worse than that you've
probably better off getting mad than
some of the other [ __ ] food you catch
that [ __ ] menu reinfect see I'm getting
[ __ ] paranoid everybody's getting
paranoid I think anyway yeah alright so
the first one we're gonna talk about
this is a movie called Polaroid now this
is a horror movie um it just dropped on
Netflix
this one had kind of like a convoluted
um backstory now this is actually the
first full length film by a Norwegian
director named Lars clever
he probably got better known like this
past year because he directed the
childsplay remake however this I liked
that child's play I did as well I didn't
I thought it was gonna be horrible but
it was actually like better than I was
it was good yeah it got the tone of the
time in a way yeah so so this was his
first movie now it was based on a short
film he made in 2015 which was also
called parent was also called Polaroid
paranoid it's like thinking about what
you were saying so yeah so this is his
feature-length debut however even though
this movie was made in 2017 it kind of
got pushed around on the schedule and
then the production company that held
the rights to it went bankrupt and then
it got bought by another studio and all
this other kind of crap now it did
actually get a theatrical release in
Germany early last year and also I think
in the UK in summer of last year but as
far as I know I don't think it got a
theatrical release here it just went
straight to VOD and it just recently
went to Netflix now the weird thing
about it is that because of all these
kind of [ __ ] going on behind the scenes
I think people were expecting this movie
like over the past couple years is sort
of built up this almost sort of like
mythical like what is in this movie that
nobody wants us to see or anything like
that but there was no reason
it was just like financial reasons like
I felt about underwater yeah I love that
movie I'm gonna plug that movie again
man I can't believe it didn't make any
money but sometimes it's not I mean like
I said sometimes it's not because
anyone's like trying to keep it under
wraps or anything like that it's just
like like I said this they made it in
the new production company went bankrupt
and it comes with it and it's like they
had to keep pushing around on the
schedule because other [ __ ] was coming
out but it seems like after child's play
the childsplay remake did pretty good
they thought that well we'll go ahead
and release this one because this was
his first movie so this is um it's pg-13
but you know don't let that really
dissuade you it was written by the same
person that wrote Hellfest who I think's
name was Blair Butler
I actually liked how fast like how fast
yeah so the thing about it is all that
won in the theaters and it was it was
satisfying it was kind of had an
old-school throwback it wasn't graphic
that's why a lot of people didn't like
it I think some people wouldn't have
blood in it yeah but it was good it was
a it was a good fun movie it was a good
movie I think it was that would have
made a great date movie yeah back when I
was a teenager
yeah it's that's the thing it's like III
know there's a thing and I think people
do I mean I think there is reason for
this um that when a horror movie comes
out and it's pg-13 like horror fans kind
of roll their eyes like a boy there we
go it's gonna be like neutered and I
think that they're you know it's
understandable that a lot of people
think that because that does happen a
lot but in some ways too it's like I
don't think the movie being a pg-13
necessarily has to mean that it's like
not scary or it's not enjoyable or
anything like that it's just a type of
thing where maybe it's not as gory as
you might like or anything so but I feel
like this movie I don't think it
suffered for the pg-13 rating because it
wasn't a gory premise
I mean the whole premise of this movie
is that there's this highschool girl
named bird and she has kind of like a
little bit of they don't go a huge
amount of the characterization and stuff
but she had kind of a back story like
her with her father dying and stuff and
you kind of like find out more about it
later on but she's kind of into old [ __ ]
she works in an antique shop with her
friend and it's like she's not she's not
like bullied or anything but she's not
like the most popular kid at school but
she does have like friends and
everything cuz she's like a little bit
weird and she likes photography and old
things and [ __ ] so it turns out that she
comes across this old Polaroid camera in
the antique shop where she works and
she's super jazzed about it and starts
taking pictures with it only to find out
that every one she takes a picture of
with this camera ends up dying yeah
horrible way there's not a lot of gore
in it but that doesn't mean that it's
not graphic a bunch of cool [ __ ] happens
in it and they're able to kind of
circumvent it there isn't a lot of blood
yeah a lot of people burn up or get
crushed up and crumpled up they they
skirt that yeah they are pretty
successful at skirting it I didn't know
it was pg-13 I want you there in
kool-aid I thought it was kind of
r-rated but so they think they did a
good job yeah you can get away with
quite a bit with a pg-13 rating yeah but
with your real graphic gore you know if
you have like excessive nudity or
excessive swearing or something like
that they usually end up giving it an R
but like I said you can get away with
quite a bit of violence and stuff in a
pg-13 so people do end up dying in this
but you know I think this isn't like a
super original premise um it reminded me
a little bit of I think it was like a
was it a Japanese or a Thai movie that
was called shudder that was sort of kind
of about a haunted camera kind of so
it's sort of a better video game called
fatal frame yeah it's not like that
maybe it is kind of like that no it
isn't yeah I'm thinking shudder was like
not exactly the same but it was like the
same kind of thing where you take a
picture with this cursed camera and then
all of a sudden the background that
wasn't they
and bird pretty quickly figures out
what's going on is trying to figure out
like what the [ __ ] is happening because
she sees like the you know the shadow
moving from picture to picture like
because I guess if you take a picture of
one person and then the demon or
whatever it is like doesn't kill you and
then you take a picture of another
person then the demon moves to that one
so it like moves it up on the list like
you're eventually gonna get [ __ ] but
the order that you get [ __ ] in has to
do with like how she takes the pictures
critique and movies as always a thing a
taste yeah I mean so III liked the movie
yeah but there was a lot of things about
that weren't to my taste yes like you
said you brought it up earlier kind of
had a convoluted story it did a bit like
horror movies too because simple
easy-to-follow to where there's kind of
like a linear progression right this one
actually kind of starts getting into
flashbacks to expect it to explain why
did the camera cameras on it I'd rather
like that I'd rather like to be told how
the camera got hard first and then what
the camera does yeah maybe that's the
child in me I don't know you know me
because I don't expect much from horror
movies I don't want to try to figure
[ __ ] out I mean really want to wonder
just tell me a story you know that mean
well I just see what unfold because the
ones we grew up on you know like [ __ ]
re-animator and from beyond they're very
linear there's no hard lis ever any kind
of flashback well yeah I guess but it's
like well the thing about it though is
that I think the reason that why a lot
of horror movies are structured in the
way that's one is structured is because
you don't necessarily want like to
front-load your movie with this is
what's going to happen like throughout
the course of the movie you want there
to be like a mystery some surprises or
something like that so it's like
somebody finds this cameras like hey
neat and then suddenly all their friends
start dying and they're like hey there's
this weird smudge in here that looks
like a person and so they're trying to
like figure it out and then later on
they kind of clue you in so you so you
can see why they should sure what is it
that we're not winning because otherwise
like
said they'd be telling you hey the
cameras cursed cuz of this and then the
rest of the movie just be it doing that
like I said it's always a matter of
taste
yeah when you're talking about this yeah
and then I kind of like so I like kind
of like [ __ ] to be like you said front
loader didn't that way I don't know
what's gonna happen in there that way
that way I don't check out of the movie
in the first 10 minutes yeah you know me
I'm just not [ __ ] patient he has a TD
or something it's not even it's just I'm
very used to being disappointed by
movies I'm 50 years old I've basically
seen everything yeah I mean so if it
hasn't really kind of hooked me in that
first 10 minutes and kept me riveted
it's not going to mostly and then when
the movies over uh I should have wasted
my time that's how I [ __ ] see it yeah
I think that's why a lot of these movies
they're [ __ ] tailored to teenagers
and people in their twenties I think
it's a little easier to impress them
they're more impressionable I don't know
about that though because I feel like if
younger people nowadays maybe they're
very morning already
alright well not just a DD but they're a
lot more cynical they've seen anything
yeah I know they're having a hard time
selling anything to them they don't like
anything well yeah that's what I mean
that's exactly they don't they like
video games movies can't compete with
video games well yeah and you can see
why that is because yeah the future is
not movies the future is in but like I
said you know I'm you know I'm a
creative person I'm a writer and stuff
like that so I'm interested in other
people's stories and like how they put
them across and stuff so like I said you
know I'm not gonna say like if I see a
movie and I think it sucks I'm gonna say
that but it's like I'm willing to give
like a lot of leeway for persons I mean
if they had reasons for doing what they
did and even though this isn't a super
original premise like I said it's it's
got like your standard teen horror movie
stuff like you know jump scares and like
people creeping down like darkened
corridors and whatnot but this was
actually um better than I was expecting
um I actually did really like the
premise of it I liked like the
creepiness of like the demon like
showing up and then like moving from
a picture I like that there was
something of like almost like a weird
like voodoo aspect where it's like if
you do something to the picture like it
happens to the real person like I like
that they brought that in I liked the
you know the wave that they gave the
backstory and then they gave you some
like uncertainty about the back story
because people gave to differing
backstories and you weren't really sure
for a little while like which one was
the truth
also um they got [ __ ] great Zabriskie
to do a cameo in this um I know her from
she's been like a bunch of David Lynch
movie she was in Inland Empire she was
in a bunch of other ones so I thought
that was super cool that she was in this
now I will say that the scene that she
was in where she's essentially telling
one of the backstories like I said you
don't know which one is true
um the way that they did that was
slightly cheesy but I found that I
didn't really mind it one thing I would
have liked I would have liked more
character development a little bit I
think Byrd was a good character she was
like the main character and she you kind
of got a vibe for her and stuff but all
her friends were like a little bit
interchangeable like you know what I
mean like there was one that was like
the kind of [ __ ] girl and then it was
like you know her lesbian best friend
that was like having problems with her
mom and but everything was just kind of
like you know just one or two sentences
or like so it would have been nicer to
kind of have them had a little bit more
character so like when some bad [ __ ] was
happening to them or when they were
threatened you would feel like more
invested in it and you'd be like more
upset about it but that said I think
this is a perfectly fine you know
mid-tier horror movie don't sit with
with you know with younger characters
like kind of a cool premise like I said
it's not super gory it's more like a
supernatural demonic ghosty type of
thing um so you know if you like that
guy yeah I'm not gonna say I'm gonna say
it's not a great movie no it's not a bad
movie it's a pretty good movie yeah I
think if I was in my twenties I probably
would have liked it better yeah well
yeah like all the characters you're
really young right now whether you're 20
right now today I don't know you're
cynical as may not like this but I
thought it was okay I think
it's pretty good it seems to be getting
like mixed reviews like I think it had I
think I looked on Rotten Tomatoes it had
like 35% or something like that with a
lot of people just saying oh you know
the same stuff basically were saying
it's all mine
it's a whole movie was made what in 1722
2017 yeah it's seventeen its lumped
around well then it wasn't enough word
curve is he he's in an upward trend
because I liked his child's play better
and I liked uh because there's the same
director right yeah yeah I think though
so he he got better
yeah that was his second feeling this
first feature this was pretty good
based on the shore I think child's play
was better the other one I kind of I
like that other one better it was a hell
that was the the same writer save Rider
I like how fast better than this I think
I liked this one slightly more than
alpha okay but it's kind of hard to pick
cuz they're they're very different
heaviness was more cheerful in a way
Hellfest was more like an old-school
black slash play not bloody this one is
more like a no this one is more like an
early 2000s Asian yeah movie a little
that's more of that type of vibe right
that's what it is so it's so like I said
it's hard to compare cuz they're two
different genres really I mean as far as
I'm concerned so on the back of that
it's a good director
yeah and like I said he definitely seems
like one to watch particularly if he
makes more horror movies I hope he does
but yeah it's on Netflix at least in the
United States so you know if you got a
couple hours to kill and you want to
check it out then check it out it's
pretty good
you
so our second movie this week was also
on Netflix and this is actually a
documentary and you know when I was
scrolling through I had to watch this
[ __ ] because this is cats the movie yeah
not cats the musical yeah it was just
like I saw the stills from that number
like what No thank you like some awful
[ __ ] dr. Seuss that looks a little
too and I like weird movies but I was
like that looks like weird in a bad way
cats isn't doesn't have a story it's not
about anything
yes that's which is fine like if you
like that in the musical and stuff and
I've been in many musicals when I was a
[ __ ] kid let me tell you something
certain [ __ ] works and a musical works
on stage it would never live it's
different many live performance people
on mic singing out of the audience has a
very very different experience than
seeing that [ __ ] well clearly because
yeah you know what look how popular cats
the live show was as opposed to help
popular cats movie versions yeah yeah
but anyway this is talking about this is
a good little documentary if you like
[ __ ] Instagram cat sounds like a new
you know the grumpy cat and all that
yeah I love look I love cats so it's
like anything on Netflix that comes up
that's about kitty cats I'm into it
although I will say that it's like one
YouTube channel was a YouTube channel
right that you introduced me that that
Korean yeah I got a club kit a critter
corner Club and it's like we're so with
kids go around like rescuing animals and
stuff and I was traumatic I really got
into it for a while but it's like I had
to stop when it was just too sad and
most of the animals that they rescued
like we're okay yeah but it's like it's
not as though they were not okay and
they do remember starving dogs that were
trapped up on top of the roof because
the [ __ ] yeah enough time locked in
there and it's like so after a while I
was like I can't it's a good channel
though it is it's called critter club
spelled with two K's yeah
yes Korean Korean was so yeah it's like
a show and Koreans man you know I lived
in Korea for a year Koreans know how to
[ __ ] tear jerk your ass there any mo
show ya MP I was just like they're
they're not like they're not like
Chinese people they're not like Japanese
people they're [ __ ] hot-blooded and
they're they're very emotional if you
make a mad to come at you but and you
they be show that yeah remember how them
go that woman went after that other
woman for starving her dog yeah that's
right
yeah but yeah it's like yeah so for a
couple nights we were like watching a
whole bunch of her it's like I can't
break your addictive it's breakin my
heart and it's funny because I was
thinking about that when we went to
independent bar last weekend they lee
who's like the bar manager he told us
he's like we found four kittens up in
the ceiling like when they were like
doing renovations or one and he's got
like a key and he's not a cat person he
is he has a dog he's like he's warm
enough to he is though it's like that
they showed me pictures they're super
cute but yeah so of course anything that
comes up on Netflix it has anything
whatsoever to do with cats I'm gonna
watch that [ __ ] because I love cats more
than life itself probably so this is
basically hockey I'm not kitty centric
you're not kitty center I like all
animals well I do too I need to I'm big
into like those down red pandas you see
this yeah they rule yeah and then man
they do some [ __ ] funny [ __ ] they do
yes I like raccoons and she had a
raccoon I never I never was able to have
a record no I had a squirrel a squirrel
that's what it was I had a squirrel I'd
like to have a squirrel too I was a kid
yeah it was I knew somebody had one of
my dad's friends had a wreck oh we had
like psychos name of splash and flash
but he saw it fall out of a [ __ ] tree
this or the baby and go into the water
when he was fishing yeah yeah it was up
in a tree something I guess the momma
took it up to a tree he couldn't get it
back he took it took it home ran splash
yeah that's how we got our squirrel he
fell out of a nest and a long tree okay
he was just like he didn't have his eyes
open yet we had him for a long time kind
of a spaz he lived in the house for a
while until he just got to did frantic
and he just kept like running away they
can become a wild squirrel laughter
can't they yeah although he died yeah
that's right you got something wrapped
around his foot but yeah so like it yeah
I love all animals too except
cockroaches not much matters well I
don't see I like spiders but I'm not
saying I see those little cute like ones
with delivery they don't like bugs a
little pedipalps and stuff but yeah well
the little jumping spiders yeah I don't
- I'm time with this [ __ ] nasty
spiders man okay but yeah I mean you
know but I've always loved cats I've
always had cats growing up so it's like
so this documentary is basically it's
kind of exploring the relationship
between cats and the Internet and why
cat videos became such a thing like in
the early days of the internet now I
will say that one thing I I wish that it
had kind of delved a little deeper into
that like the first you know 10 15
minutes of the documentary they kind of
give like sort of a brief history of you
know the early days of the Internet and
like how for whatever reason like cat
memes became a thing and they talked a
little bit about like I Can Has
Cheezburger and even like going back
farther than that like the little text
cats you know that people used to do
like with the code and whatnot and it's
like and that's kind of cool but then
pretty quickly it jumps into you know
the bulk of the documentary which seems
to be I've seen some reviews like kind
of criticize this for being essentially
a commercial for Instagram which I guess
it kind of is because I mean the main
part of the documentary is focusing on
the two people that run cats of
Instagram and also like several people
like the guy who owned low bub and you
know some other people that have like
cats that are sort of like Instagram
stars and so it's like interviewing them
and like talking about you know what
they do with their cats and and how they
get all these likes and stuff like that
so it's almost kind of like I was I was
making jokes - baby cookie while I was
watching this it's like hey cookie you
want to be a star a lot of money be made
taking pictures of damn cats it's so
ridiculous it is but there's so many
people doing it
the relatives probably would have had to
get into it like at the beginning and
it's like they even talked to this woman
and I guess it didn't really occur to me
before I watch this but like once I saw
that saw it I was kind of like oh of
course
so now there's like a whole and then
maybe there's more than one but now
there's like a whole basically a whole
[ __ ] advertising agency and that's
all they do is manage people whose pets
are like Instagram stars right like now
they need because that it's like a huge
because there's not only the thing where
you have like all these followers and
like you get but you also get like
[ __ ] you know corporate sponsorship
and stuff like that like a lot of pet
food companies will like want to hire
your cat and all this other kind of
stuff so they have their own like
[ __ ] advertising agencies now so so
it kind of went into that a lot and I
found that really interesting although
like I said I can see how some people
would feel like oh this just seems like
an Instagram commercial you know for
these specific people that they
interviewed like I said it's the guy
that owned little bub who actually seems
like he seemed like a really cool dude
because I mean his little cat you know
little bub everybody knows him yeah he
didn't really seem to start out with you
know the intention of making him like
internet famous making the cat internet
famous just kind of happened
because the kitty was so you know kind
of funny-looking and like he was look
really cute and everything so and and he
actually that guy that own little bub he
actually like set up I think he said
it's a setup like a Cat Rescue
Foundation like with the money and stuff
like that so I I do feel like his heart
was in the right place some of the
people that came along later I'm not
really sure if their intentions are
entirely pure especially the one couple
that were like dressing up the cat and
it's like I'm not really sure the cat
seemed pretty chill to my bub know this
this other cat that was I can't remember
which cat it was but they put in like in
all these like crazy costumes and stuff
people do that to their kids true but
it's like I don't know I'm some cats
like it and or probably don't mind it
but I feel like a lot of cats wouldn't
like that cookie would probably think
that was a game maybe cuz I've
considered like
getting little outfits for cookie she
likes to put the collar on off although
it took her a while to tell what she
understood she understood it eventually
that when she went outside if she has to
have a collar on so because it's
reflective what we want people that
she's asking to go out I don't want her
to look like a damn straight cat so you
got to put a collar on yeah and then
I'll show her the collar and she'll have
to go out I'll show the collar and
she'll come and go I mean the first
couple I bought like this pack of
because I knew that she wasn't gonna be
happy about it so about like a pack of
six collars
she lost well she took off the first one
like almost immediate I never found out
and we never found it I found a second
one though the second one we found like
in the backyard oh no no it was pink so
it was the first one yeah the second one
we didn't [ __ ] yeah I think it was light
blue never found it yeah never found
that white blue reflective stripe on it
I just found it sitting out in the field
where she pulled it off yeah she has she
puts her little paw and she's just like
going because it's got an emergency
release on it yeah so it doesn't like it
snagged on anything but it's like so I
don't know I'm kind of like yes it's
adorable like when you put outfits on
cats and like I said I would love to
have I wanted to get like a little
Halloween costume for cookie hold on
hold on though we're going off on the
kid oh I'm just saying no I'm a food no
I was talking about the couple that was
in this dress their cat it but I was
like I'm always kind of like conflicted
about that because I feel like like I
said maybe your cat's different but it's
like I do kind of feel like most cats
don't like being dressed up like that
and also there's this one girl on there
who had a big super fat cat and that was
kind of his claim to fame was like being
super fat and the cat was on a diet but
they kind of went into a little bit
she's like well he's like famous for
being fat thank you fat so it's like if
he loses weight she's gonna like lose
all these followers itself I'm like
that's kind of a [ __ ] up thing to be
thinking about but yeah so if you like
cats this was like a fun you know just
fluffy throw away kind of documentary
like I said I would have liked it better
if they'd gone more into the history of
cats and that was like why cats became
like the the unofficial like internet
sponsors for whenever the hell change
wise you like
and not dogs because it goes back
thousands of years people kept these
cats because they were cute and they
raised them so they were cute
there are even old paintings you know of
yea people with their cats so it always
sold yeah always is just it's part of
human nature but it's weird that now
that you have the Internet this is just
an Internet version of what they were
always been doing but what I mean was
that it's weird that it was cats and not
dogs because it does seem like there are
more dog owners and more people are
adopting because you cats are smaller
maybe and they can calmly sit there and
maybe take a photo you could probably do
with a little dog too but yeah people do
it with their dogs I've seen I've seen
medieval paintings of maybe not quite
medieval maybe maybe Renaissance
paintings of little girls dressed up
with ferrets and Airmen's yeah that they
played with those two or my fur
Garrett's make really good pets yeah I
had one was a little kids dance till the
little clowns they are yeah I knew a guy
that had a girlfriend had a couple of
yeah problem is those if they get out
they never come back yeah I don't have
any kind of homing instincts yeah
they're just keep going in a straight
line yeah there's no find a better house
they don't really have a sense of home I
don't think yeah just keep running
I guess because they're not really they
weren't really bred for that
domesticated in the same way that
captain yeah it's just a little hunting
animal to get rabbits out of wholesome
they are a domestic animal they're not
wild yeah and they've been around for
you know probably thousands of years
although actually I think it's an
American continent animal but they took
them back to Europe this is you know
probably out in 45 1516 hundreds maybe
maybe a little bit later but they are
the ones that you have now are
domesticated yeah the black-footed
ferrets wild yeah that lived out in the
West that hunted like prairie dogs and
ground hogs that's that's what that was
yeah back on a time when prairie dog
mounted be the size of like [ __ ] four
states that was true yeah but you know
they converted it all the cattle farm
land right and the cows were stepping in
the hall yeah breaking their legs off so
they wiped that they wiped a pair of
prairie dogs
out but they beat them back down into
controllable sizes yeah because it's
their their burrows literally they said
that covers whole states I believe it
just an interlocking damn burrow of
[ __ ] it's like a little prairie dog
yeah
prairie dog much prairie dogs are
breeding like they breed nice you know
literally yeah but yeah so like I said
this is it's a very surface level
documentary but if you you know are
really into like cats of Instagram and
are into like you know the individual
cats and like seeing like their owners
and what they go through like trying to
get followers and all that kind of stuff
you know this is a perfectly fun little
documentary I had a good time with it um
you know I tried to get maybe cookie to
watch it but she wouldn't she knows the
difference between real life and TV it's
hard to get her interested she'll watch
a screen but she doesn't hold her
attention yeah she kind of looks at the
screen and if we're watching a horror
movie and somebody starts screaming yeah
she starts getting upset
yeah she'll look at us like what's all
that screaming
she doesn't scary music isn't it it's
not just our imagination because I've
seen videotapes of [ __ ] Bulldogs
losing their locking mind at [ __ ]
like Jason on Y the 13th and the damn
dog from the thing yeah when it turned
into Moss or the [ __ ] oh that video
yeah trying to dam attack the screen and
[ __ ] needs to barking and calling for
help more help in helping and then like
you know Jason or Michael Myers sneaking
up on somebody and the dogs trying to
warn the people he's coming yeah doesn't
do that but she does kind of like if
like something bad is happening she will
like turn around and look and like look
up says everything okay what's happening
and so we teaser were just like don't
watch that movie was that where she
looked back and was going like what the
[ __ ] is I don't even
remember yes it was there was a woman
she was screaming or something getting
getting attacked by something and she
yeah she looked at us like this and even
a couple times when we were up on the
bed watching a movie in there cookie was
sitting in the middle like Tom put what
it was like really gory yeah but yeah so
you know this is on Netflix right now I
mean the title is kind of dumb cats the
movie and they even did it like hashtag
cats underscore the underscore movie so
you know what I mean
so you know so if you want to like
search for it under that so you don't
get like the [ __ ] about the kids musical
cuz no one needs to see that one but
this is actually pretty good okay if
you're into cats
you
so the third movie we saw this week just
dropped on shudder just Rob Zombie's
three from hell yeah not bad but not
great either yeah it's just this one
just um they actually did a couple night
event for this like remember fathom
events was having it and we just didn't
get around to seeing it in the theater
so we just were just kind of like
waiting for it to come out
the thing about Rob Zombie's movies I
really liked house of 1000 corpses which
I saw in the theater back in the day I
think it came out in 2003 um I really
liked Devil's Rejects yeah we just
actually watched that again like just a
couple weeks ago and I just liked it
just as much um some of his other movies
like I really hated his Halloween a big
a lot of it nobody's you know didn't see
me very popular I never saw it I didn't
like that it demystified Michael Myers I
think that was a big mistake um you know
there was just a lot of [ __ ] about it I
didn't like I saw that in the theater
but I just remembered not really liking
it now it seems like some of his more
recent movies like Lords of Salem it
seems like a lot of people kind of liked
that one I haven't seen it yet 31
everyone seemed to hate like they
thought it was a mess so I've been
looking forward to see that seeing this
one because I like you know these movies
like in the Firefly trilogy as they call
it and I have to say there's something
about this one
man I just I can't put my finger on it
like the Devil's Rejects
great movie this one I just feel like I
mean all of Rob Zombie's movies they
have like a little bit of an aspect of
like try hard to them and I feel like
this was that like writ large if that
makes any sense you know guys I kind of
know you're talking about that's not how
I'm seeing it yeah I see the main
problem with this movie where the
problem the thing that causes this not
to be really an excellent movie alright
was the fact that it's 20 years later
yeah there's too damn late it was
because the first two were only like two
years apart yeah it's and you can tell
of course you know Sid Haig is not
feeling well and he's only in one
one or two scenes in the very yeah he's
only like in the first five minutes
performance isn't all that great you can
tell us dude sick
he looks [ __ ] fantastic look scariest
[ __ ] because he's just skinny as [ __ ]
his [ __ ] beard he just he looks
[ __ ] weird alright which plays well
his performance isn't that good that I
could tell his energy levels pretty low
yeah I could tell you which is why he
ended up not being in the movie yeah I
can tell that he's not feeling well yeah
because it's been so long I think the
energy level of all the performers is
not quite the same I mean you know the
the main guy is close to 70 now yeah
it's it's hard to sell this story with
those characters now they've they've
aged
yeah it's be honest um what's him sherry
yes Jerry looks great she's [ __ ] that
pretty as hell
prettiest yet she was even 20 years ago
and she was 40 not I think yeah yeah
about my age yeah there's a couple years
older than I am
yeah and she was great but there's some
kind of a youthful exuberance to the
cast 20 years ago yeah doing a movie
that's very experimental and very edgy
so I think it's easier for them to as
performers to sell this I think that's
where the problem is yeah it kind of
gotten out of hang of these characters
probably - the story isn't quite as good
it's not it doesn't have a real
compelling now I was watching some other
reviews if they had it in the component
is yeah and it and the it's not those
other two movies just rolled forward
like a damn steamroller right you
followed the whole thing this one no it
slows down in certain areas it's uneven
it's copy and then they end up in Mexico
and it's kind of weird there and it's
not there's a bunch of unbelievable [ __ ]
happens in it you know what I mean but
just the way the way the way the story
comes across it just kind of comes
across as like it was kind of just
thrown together and I've seen other
reviews that said it felt like two or
three different movies yeah that we're
kind of like because we have
first started watching it when they were
doing the kind of like documentary style
type of thing where they were talking
about I mean here's the thing now at the
end of the Devil's Rejects um you know
the very iconic scene where you know
where Otis and Captain Spaulding and
baby are in the car Freebird is blaring
and they're basically just like pumped
full of bullets yeah so that kind of
would have been a good ending yeah
however they since this movie came out
it's like they had to like backpedal and
say oh how did they got the H got shot
like 20 times and yesterday I survived
which seems a little unlikely right from
out of the gate yeah I mean the other
two movies you could kind of believe
that maybe this was a story that
actually happened in the world world
yeah even though it was stylish yeah you
know this is pure fantasy none of this
could have happened pretty as it's very
that it's very very I mean they got
attacked by a gang of damn Mexican and
they're all wearing luchador masks and
that and then all but I like that all
the guns that they have or not
period-correct that's those are all good
88 yeah those are all they are 15s from
this year yeah yeah and I mean they've
got [ __ ] Magpul [ __ ] furniture on
a bit [ __ ] you know yeah guys that know
what it is just seeing you know what
you're seeing so this is becoming a
cartoon or a comic book movie it's
always been kind of just okay I mean the
characters you know these three
characters have always been sort of like
cartoons um you can tell you know Rob
Zombie is super into like grindhouse
type movies and like old like
exploitation movies and I'm not like and
it has that in it he has those jobs like
he really does know all these movies
there's a lot of oh ma jizz in this too
like other movies like fight for your
life and things like that which that's
cool um you know and there's a lot of
like really funny like cameos like
[ __ ] I think that was Clint Howard
playing like baggy britches the clown or
whatever he was and [ __ ] like that so
there's like a lot of funny and I like
the new character because Sid Haig was
so ill and couldn't be in the movie for
more than a few minutes I mean his
character is pretty much like killed off
like in the gas chamber or whatever like
very very early in the movie and then
they needed a third person so they have
like another character who's I think
he's Otis his half brother or cousin or
something like that named foxy and that
and I like that character and I kind of
liked the interactions between him and
Otis but I don't know there's just
something about this one it didn't I
couldn't like catch the wave of it man
it's just like like I said I liked like
when it first started and they had that
documentary thing going where they were
talking about you know the three from
hell they're in prison and you know it
was kind of going through all their
court [ __ ] and it was they did a little
bit of a Manson Family thing where they
were like had they'd become like these
anti heroes and stuff like I liked the
way they were going with that but then
it kind of goes into well baby in prison
and then like Dee Wallace he's playing
like the prison matron although I didn't
recognize her for a second because she
had glasses and she's all like ugly dope
and stuff yeah cute woman man especially
back on and back in the day yeah cuz I
was like hey yeah when she was in what
was what was the name of that one foot
frighteners frighteners yeah yeah I was
in my 20s and she was like prior in her
40s and I was like the first time I
[ __ ] like recognized it she's wearing
that little [ __ ] mini dresses [ __ ]
running around the shotgun yeah so yeah
so she was in this well although like I
said I didn't recognize her until like a
few minutes like into the movie um so
for a long time it's like you have ODIs
and foxy like running around on the
outside and they like take the the
prison guy from where baby is being held
the prison like takes their family
hostage to get baby released and it's
like then baby is like I guess she's
been in prison for ten years and she's
like gone crazier than she was before
and that was played a little too over
the top for me I mean and I know that's
stupid to say for a Rob Zombie MOOC is
all over the top but I just I don't know
that it I just felt like it's a little
too much just a little too much you know
- whoa whoa what I really put this for
me the first two movies were kind of
plausible that's kind of how I made him
[ __ ] disturbing yeah some like that
maybe some what are the Devil's Rejects
yeah maybe something like dr. Satan
could exist man that [ __ ] freaky yeah
you saw dude like that you know I mean
all that you know what he did well you
know what he did [ __ ] take a dude if
I could cut him up turn him into a damn
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] mur man that's
a weird [ __ ] you saw that why do so even
in the other movies so what ended up
happening cuz I guess he got killed were
found by the cops I don't know they
didn't even mention him yeah that's what
I mean that seemed like a cool pair
remember we some happen to and I'm
forgetting about it
yeah I've been a while since I've seen
ya but the because it was kind of
plausible it made me the [ __ ] terror
of the victims and like the suffering of
the victims more realistic yeah because
this one you know I mean you go like
whoa I'd be kind of disturbed by some of
that [ __ ] you know what they were doing
or the [ __ ] people in the damn hotel
room you know that yeah that really
about it was like that really bothered
me but this one it's it's it's so kind
of a comic book movie kind of you don't
care about anybody gets killed it's just
it doesn't have the same impact not in
the same pack the Devil's Rejects
was like it's kind of weird but it's
like his movies are very like almost
like nihilistic because it's like no no
they're not heroes it's like you're not
supposed to like them and like they do
this fucked-up [ __ ] but then in a way
it's almost kind of like this one is
trying to make you sympathize with them
a little right I don't know if that was
his intention yeah and it just seemed it
just came off as to me it came off as a
cash grab it did any of its kind of like
tired yeah had some good [ __ ] in it and
I liked you know some of the
cinematography I like I like some of the
cameos I like some of stuff but it just
felt like like you said it felt like it
was they left it too long like ever was
kind of old everyone seemed worn out
it's like Sid Haig is not in it and I've
just you know other than the first
couple minutes and he's made that movie
that's what I need in and harder he
partly made it him not being in this you
can really see how he's in it but he's
not in it for very long just to begin
and you can tell he's not feeling good
yeah so it's like you can tell how
integral he was was a success of the
first two movies if they were gonna make
a third part they should have done this
like alar years later after after
Devil's Rejects yeah it was
[ __ ] bid poppin because it was so
long I wouldn't have made this movie so
it kind of comes off as made other he's
got other movies he could have made I
wouldn't have made this movie comes off
as a cash grab
no this marketing-wise this is how you
make some money but story wise this
isn't what you do yeah what you do is
you do at a tangential story in that
same universe you could do that or maybe
some kind of a flashback of who dr.
Satan was how that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah I
would have gone I could I would have
done something in that same universe
with that same tone as Devils reject but
done it from a different angle yeah
related to that story I almost feel like
and I don't know if this is true or not
but I almost feel like what ended up
happening was that maybe Rob Zombie's
last movie 31 and like I said I can't
you know speak to what it's like cuz I
haven't seen it it's on shudder we
should probably watch it one of these
days but it really did not get a very
good reception so I almost feel like Rob
Zombie is kind of like okay well
everybody just seems to want me to go
back to you know the Firefly family
because everybody liked those two movies
so much yeah so it almost seemed like
okay well is this what you want I'm
gonna revisit it right when really there
was no reason to I mean the end of the
Devil's Rejects
that [ __ ] shootout where they all got
blasted full of bullets that seemed like
a pretty definitive ending and a good
way to end it like kind of going out in
a blaze of glory type of thing but so I
just feel like this movie it's not a bad
movie it just seems like it wasn't super
necessary and I didn't really get it
seemed kind of disjointed and I couldn't
really get into it I couldn't get into
the movies headspace I couldn't you know
what I mean I I found it a little bit
boring to be honest with you a little
bit I want to like the movie I did too
I was excitable wanna I want to I want
to know if it stands up to multiple
viewings maybe gets better on other
viewings I mean yeah sometimes that
happens
I remember seeing Devil's Rejects in the
first time I saw it I was like [ __ ] yeah
you can same with the house of 2000 yeah
I saw that movie I loved it yeah and it
was like me you feel bad whoa
I'm said again yeah I mean that was that
kind of [ __ ] yes and I think going back
to that same family approaching this
from this angle with those same
characters was not the best way to do it
or a story wise maybe this is how you
maybe you make money yeah probably but
this did make a lot of money yes yeah I
okay
then we got another free movie from that
family what I would do is make a fourth
movie and go back tell us about dr.
Satan yeah like I said make a doctor see
that's me that would be better because
that seemed like such a cool yeah one
sense was murder and they didn't really
go into it like he kind of forgot about
it
yeah this is good with that yeah let's
go back to when how he became that and
you know when these people were young
and [ __ ] yeah maybe that that's why I
had to do it that's a movie right there
yeah cuz it's probably some untold [ __ ]
you get somebody to place Ed's character
when he was young yeah something like
that
well like I said it's just like I said
this wasn't it wasn't a bad movie it's
like you know I watched it and it was
but you know the acting was fine like I
liked all the characters and stuff like
that but it just seemed like it seemed a
little bit like a rehash I mean because
him like them keeping all the people
hostage like in the room it was just
kind of like Devil's Rejects and it's
like so it was kind of like hitting the
same beats again and like I said sid
haig not being in it was kind of like a
big downer even though it's you know
nothing wrong with Foxy's character you
know who was played by it she did a
great job
she did a good job you know um no the
the guys other guy that was in it yeah
yeah that's right
what was his name Richard or a break yes
your break is that his name yeah he was
in he was in a lot of so he was just in
the rhythm section which we saw a guy in
the wheelchair yeah I loved I loved his
work hey you think wasn't he in Game of
Thrones I want to say he was in Hannibal
Rising I loved his work and Hannibal
uprising he was one of got choke choke
by this horse one tree yeah he's he's
good he's a good dude here's the thing
man this is not a bad movie it's not
it's just it's just a devil they don't
all Hank it's all the aspects of a
Devil's Rejects is a horror
act to fall it is yeah especially after
so much time has passed yeah with those
original actors yeah I mean just
we got another movie yeah that that way
got another movie you know I mean maybe
it's gonna have a mixed reaction but it
was what a lot of people wanted yeah
artistically man I'd go back and tell us
about dr. Satan I'd be dead for equals
and like I said it's with all fresh new
cast that's [ __ ] young enough to play
all those yeah and like what they were
like in their 20s or teens and how all
that [ __ ] happened with a main character
of [ __ ] dr. Satan yeah you know and
he'd probably been in his 30s or
something yeah at that time you know and
I mean I might be some weird [ __ ] bad
there's all kinds of stories you could
tell oh yeah and you know I'd be
perfectly willing to give this another
go you know what I mean and especially
maybe after I've watched you know 31 and
Lords of Satan and stuff because I have
Lords of Satan Lords of Salem because I
haven't seen those two you haven't seen
that one but um I think I'm pretty sure
31 is on shudder maybe Lords of Salem is
actually I think Lords of Salem might be
on to be another thing about it but um
you know this is just kind of one that
maybe one give it a second look I
wouldn't fall I wouldn't call Rob Zombie
[ __ ] trihard ease though I would kind of
put it in the same kind of like in the
same genre as Tarantino Tarantino kind
of does that same yeah very similar Hopi
[ __ ] b-movie [ __ ] 70s suckin
grindhouse comeback so that's what it is
because those movies were kind of like
that they were yes so it is what it's in
it is what it is yeah you know it's it's
part of that genre at that tone that
he's going for you know man yeah and and
I get that it was like I said I I just
don't think it was as successful this
time around as it was no it's real hard
to follow up [ __ ] devil from Devil's
Rejects especially after this much time
yeah with those actors and stuff with
that with that [ __ ] team and with
that same story trying to continue it
after they got shot up the pieces and
[ __ ] and then they go on the run and
it's almost like a hangout
yeah they're not really it's not as
really compelling is that is it what I'd
rather have them go back and tell us
about doctor doctor say yeah I agree
yeah I'm thinking that's gonna be
something along the lines of
Frankenstein's army that's how I
expected I've got a picture dr. Satan
being something kind of like
Frankenstein dr. Frankenstein yeah yeah
but yeah you know it's like I said I'll
give this another go at some point and
you know watch them as other new ones
and see how I feel about him and see to
sail on one yeah but it's a lot of
people seem to like that one just
because that seemed like a little bit of
a different direction
Robin these ones were um but you know
like I said it's but I've liked brought
some of Rob Zombie's other movies other
than like I said the Halloween remake
which I did not like I think he made a
sequel to that and I didn't even bother
seeing it because I hated that first one
but um I just didn't like like I said I
didn't like don't show Michael Myers as
like a little abused kid and all that
it's like that's I don't like just
demystifying you know understand
especially slasher
I just think that's like a dumb thing to
do it undercuts their Menace but yeah so
this one you know it seems like it's
gotten kind of mixed reviews like some
people really liked it some people
thought it was the worst movie ever made
um you know what I mean you ever made
come on well well maybe like the worst
movie of this past year or whatever but
you know if you've seen the first two if
you like the first two then check it out
and see how you feel about it I think it
was you know probably unnecessary but it
had some good [ __ ] in it it's the worst
out of the three well you definitely
easily so it's not a bad movie but yeah
it's not terrible and like I said I'll
probably give it another sit through and
see how I feel about it after I seen a
second
you